And you know,
because of that you all think,
well,
you're in control of yourself,
but don't be thinking that that's just
not right.
I mean if you look at how the brain is
structured,
for example,
the Hypothalamus,
which is a really important part of the
brain,
it basically,
it basically establishes the framework
of reference and the actions,
the framework of reference within which,
and the actions you take in order to
fulfill basic biological needs.
So the hypothalamus makes you thirsty
and the hypothalamus makes you hungry
and it makes you sexually aroused.
If it puts you into a state of defensive
aggression and it,
it actually also makes you explore and
be curious.
All of that,
hypothalamic.
It's an amazing structure.
And then,
and,
and it's really small and it's right at
the base of the brain.
Um,
and you could imagine it as something
that has tremendously powerful
projections upward throughout the rest
of the brain into the emotional systems
and the cortical systems and all of
that,
like tree trunk size connections,
you know,
metaphorically speaking.
And then the cortex has these little
like vine,
like tendrils going down to regulate the
hypothalamus,
you know,
and if it's,
when push comes to shove,
man,
the hypothalamus that thing wins.
And so,
you know,
you get people now and then who have a
hypothalamic dysfunction and one of them
produces a condition called,
I can't remember it.
It's not dip.
So mania,
although it's,
it's like that doesn't matter.
It produces an uncontrollable thirst.
And so what will happen is that people
who have this hypothalamic problem will
drown themselves by drinking water,
which,
which you can do by the way.
Uh,
and so they just cannot get enough water
and there's no stopping them,
right?
No,
no more than there would be stopping you
if you were suffering from raging
thirst.
It's like it's a happy day when the
hypothalamus is not telling you what to
do.
And you know,
you live in such a civilized state that
most of the time,
roughly speaking,
you're tranquil and satisfied and more
or less you can imagine yourself as a
peaceful,
you know,
productive well meaning entity.
But don't be thinking that that's what
you'd be if you were putting the right
situation because that's just not right
at all.
So,
you know,
lots of times soldiers developed post
traumatic stress disorder because they
go out of the battlefield,
they're kind of naive.
They're young guys,
you know,
and,
uh,
it actually is worse if they're not that
bright.
It turns out because having a lower Iq
is one of the things that predisposes
you to post traumatic stress disorder.
But anyways,
they go out in the battlefield and they
see what they're capable of under
battlefield conditions.
And like,
you know,
we,
we had been fighting wars for a very
long time,
millions of years.
You know,
chimps basically have wars with other
chimps,
the troops,
right?
Because the juveniles will patrol the
perimeter perimeter of their territory
and if they find other chimps from other
troops that they outnumber,
they will tear them to pieces like in
chimps are really,
really strong.
And so when I say they'll tear them to
pieces,
I mean that literally,
you know,
they,
they tear them to pieces.
And Jane Goodall discovered that
originally in 19 seventies and she
didn't even report it for awhile because
she was so shocked,
you know,
she kind of assumed like most followers
of Ruth's soul,
that the human proclivity for warfare
was part.
That part.
That was something that was a uniquely
human,
you know,
it had something to do with our,
our unique self consciousness or
intelligence or something like that.
She had no idea that it was rooted that
deeply,
you know,
we,
we split from chimps about six,
7 million years ago,
something like that.
And so we were patrolling and territory.
We were gang members 7 million years
ago.
And you know,
at that that's,
that's minimum estimation because of
course that ancestor shaded back maybe
$20 million years into entities that
were roughly primate like and so
territoriality and the.
And the proclivity to defend territory
is so deeply embedded in us.
It's,
it's,
it's like,
it's like it's the,
the control center for our whole brain.
And so there isn't anything more
important to us,
I would say.
Then maintaining the match between what
we want to have happen and what other
people are doing in response to our
actions.
Like that's that that's what we want and
as long as that matches maintained,
then our emotional systems and I would
say anxiety is probably primary in that
regard.
Our emotional systems remain inhibited.
They're on,
they're ready like,
like a nuclear reactor.
Rods are on and the rest of the brain
dampens them down.
But it's like if you don't want them to
take time to start up,
man,
you want them to be on at a,
at a 10th of a second's notice when it's
necessary.
And so you know,
that's kind of why.
Well,
if you look at a wild animal,
it's like it's alert,
you know,
it's ready to dark this way or that way,
especially a prey animal instantaneously
and it has reflex is built into it as
you do that will respond way before your
conscious.
So for example,
if you happen to be walking down a trail
and you detect something snake like in
the periphery,
you'll leap away before you even know
that you lapped.
And that's because it takes a fair bit
of time to actually see a snake,
by which I mean form a conscious
representation of the snake,
you know,
maybe it takes a quarter of a second or
something like that,
or even longer,
but doesn't matter.
Maybe it takes 10.
No 20th of a set a 10th of a second.
But the thing about the damn snake is
it's way faster than that.
It's really fast.
That thing,
and it coevolved with primates by the
way.
And so it can nail you like way faster
than you can look at it.
So you have your eyes map,
snake like objects,
right onto your reflexes so that the
eyes go,
the eyes make you jump,
and then they see after that's like,
yeah,
well now you can see that's no problem,
you know,
so.
All right,
all.
Alright now what I would say that what
we do is we live in a shared story and
the story is a way of looking at the
world and its way of acting in the world
at the same time.
And that story has to operate within
narrow parameters.
And this is something that's
extraordinarily important to understand
because this is something I think that
piaget figured out,
John Piaget figured out better than
anyone else.
I think he really got this right.
And by the way,
one of the things that piaget was trying
to do,
you never hear about how strange these
great thinkers are.
But Piaget was a very strange guy and he
was a.
He was a hyper genius.
He was offered the curatorship of a
bloody museum when he was 10 years old,
you know,
because he wrote this little paper on
mollusks,
which parent was very good.
And so they offered him the curatorship
of a museum and his parents wrote back
and said,
well,
you know,
no,
probably not because he said he's
actually tad.
And so that was piaget man,
the guy who was a genius and you know,
he,
he was actually motivated by the desire
to reconcile science and religion.
That was,
that was actually his entire motivation
for what he did.
You'd never hear that.
But that's,
that's the case.
And so piaget was very interested in how
you produce structures that enable you
to regulate yourself.
Because you're like a kind of a,
a colony of strange sub animals that
have to figure out how to get along so
that you can sort of be one thing.
You kind of learned that I would say
between the ages of two and four as
you're being socialized,
you know,
how erratic two year olds are.
I mean,
they're a blast and it's partly because
they were erratic.
It's like they're unbelievably happy and
then they're unbelievably hungry and
then they're really hot and then they're
really upset and crying,
you know?
And then they're really scared.
It's like an,
all of that is just untrammeled and so
it's really fun to be around them,
especially when they're happy because
they're so happy that it's just,
you know,
you don't ever get to be that happy and
so it's nice to be around the two year
old because you can kinda feel that
again,
you know,
and a lot of what the.
One of the horrible things about being a
parent is that you spend a tremendous
amount of your time making your child
less happy.
And the reason for that is that positive
emotion is a very impulsive,
you know,
and you know because everybody says,
well,
you should be happy.
It's like,
well no,
when you're happy you're actually quite
stupid.
And so because happiness makes you
impulsive,
happiness makes happiness,
says hey,
things are really good right now.
Get what you can while the getting's
good.
And so as a like,
if you're hyper optimistic,
manic will say it's like every stock
investment looks like a really good
stock investment.
It's like you won't spend all your money
because look at,
there's those wonderful things
everywhere and you could do such great
things with them.
And then you know,
you spend all your money and then you
crash and you think,
Oh God,
my life's over,
you know,
because I just,
I just spent all my money on all this
useless stuff.
And it's all under the grip of
impulsive,
positive emotion,
you know?
And so when,
when you're telling your kids to be
quiet and settled down,
it isn't because they're making a lot of
noise.
Being in pain is because they're running
around like wild baboons having a blast
and disrupting things like mad,
you know,
you got kids,
you got to settle down,
you know,
like quit having so much fun and it's,
it's kind of awful that you do that,
but,
but you do.
And that's because the emotions and the
motivations have to be brought into like
a relationship with one another within
the person.
So that,
you know,
one thing I remember with my son who is
quite,
he's quite disagreeable by temperament,
which is actually a good thing as far as
I'm concerned,
although it brings its own challenges.
And so with my daughter when she was
misbehaving,
she was pretty agreeable and uh,
you know,
if she was misbehaving I can basically
just look at her and then she'd quit,
you know,
but my son,
it was like,
that was just nothing.
You're looking at me.
It's like,
no,
that's just not going to go anywhere,
man.